in southwestern China engineers are
putting the finishing touches on a grand
astronomy facility a half kilometre wide
dish nestled in the mountains that will
gather radio signals from the cosmos
fast set to be the world's largest radio
telescope is modeled on the second
largest dish in the world the Arecibo
Observatory started in 2011 the cost of
construction for the fast facility is
estimated to be a hundred and eighty
million dollars spherical dishes reflect
and concentrate incoming waves from a
range of angles but not on to a single
point delivering a distorted image to
receivers
fast is breaking new ground with a
design that pulls a section of the dish
into a gradually moving parabola an
array of actuators pull a 300 meter
section into a temporary shape this can
be aimed at and tracked cosmic objects
as the Earth rotates the receiver moves
in concert with the axis of the parabola
this brings the benefits of a rotating
tilting antenna to a dish that is firmly
fixed in place single dishes excel at
observing point sources like neutron
stars and it's scanning a multitude of
frequencies in this search for
extraterrestrial intelligence when it
comes online the world's largest radio
telescope will also catalog pulsars as
well as probe gravitational waves dark
matter and a recently discovered
phenomenon called fast radio bursts
you